what's up tatk Army I about to say fam
Army fam whatever you want to call
yourselves this is a special bonus
episode of the fire and the kid with our
boys from Legion of skanks this podcast
went down at skankfest and it was live
on mint at skankfest but Lis Gomez was
genuinely nice enough to send it to your
boy so we can give it out to you guys so
please enjoy fire the kid live with the
Legion of skanks big j o oerson Louis J
Gomez and also my fave Dave Smith and it
is live from skankfest in Vegas so enjoy
few housekeeping notes for again this
juicy live episode with the skankfest
boys in Legion of skanks I will be in
Niagara Falls November 4th and 5th
Niagara Falls New York it's at the cica
casino out there those shows are almost
sold out it's one show Friday night one
show Saturday Saturday night November
4th and 5th and then to wrap up the year
I'm in Chicago December 8th and 9th two
shows Friday two shows Saturday tickets
at thick boy.com my boy Brian Ken will
be in good nights and that's in rally
new North Carolina good nights in North
Carolina That's Thursday November 9th
Friday November 10th Saturday November
11th then he is at yuck yucks in Calgary
November 16th through the 18th that's in
Calgary Canada it's going to be freezing
but Ken will be okay so please enjoy
this very special episode of fighting
the kid with the Legion of skanks
appreciate it enjoy yes we it again the
F in theid this is really the fighter in
the kid come on
baby
how we doing I made it I [__] made it
the belly of the Beast the belly of the
Beast
woo what's up skate
f look at these boys you want to sit
there and I'll sit here you want op
let's book Let's book at him in case
trouble breaks out these boys and then
you give me a signal and we'll [__]
converge we'll sandwich him you know
what I'm saying I'm not going to lie I
thought K was going to miss it that been
a terrible look dude all I know is I'm
56 and this is very rare there was a gal
in her like she was like 30 and she was
giving me business she said I like your
cashmir sweat that never happened that
never happened all right
anyway all I got I like your cashmere
sweater yeah I'm the only one wearing
cashmere in this whole [__] place
sorry everyone can we can we I have some
whiskey please thanks very much hey B
can we bring out our guest we got some
special guests for this you know what
let's just cut to it let's get to it huh
all right let's bring him out you you
you the skankfest crew know these boys
it is the Legion of
[Applause]
skank the king
Gomez the great Dave Smith and of course
big
J
this is good you guys get the coveted
back
angle this is incred I'm so excited I
can't believe Lewis is going to fist
fight Brendan sha on stage on stage in
front of all of you people time to go
viral [__] let's go pile
on holy [__] Lewis is going to commit
suicide by
Sha he's so much bigger than you guys
realize holy [__] he feels like ran it
it's so much easier to talk [__] on the
internet oh my God this guy's great in
person holy [__] I I'm just here for the
nude roast that's I just wanted to watch
the nude roast the naked roast hell yeah
Hey listen there's nobody it's right
after this the naked roast there's not a
single attractive person in the naked
roast don't you worry no yeah well
that's why I'm excited now it's Brian
K's going to do
it
oh man I still I still have no great
pubic hair and I'm working with a PE you
got them old balls though I got some old
balls bro got some old balls I bet your
dick is [__] I got a heavy nice it's
weathered it's weathered I look like the
letter L no I'm sure it's like you guys
you guys catch got a lot of vein [__]
and it's like scene stuff right and he
doesn't go all the way up anymore it
just goes straight out it just kind of
like like a just kind of like it's lazy
it's like I'm not going to go and it
nose looks like a great white shark just
been through some [__] some stuff some
Barnacles on them or those warts could
we could we convince either of you guys
to judge the naked roast tonight judging
the naked roast Jason Ellis is judging
it he's got a [__] heavy [__]
piece yeah dude Karen fan is judging it
she's actually going full nter pussy's
going to be out you don't have to pay
for only
fans uh and then I think it's any idea
how much money she's losing by doing
this and then I think Ari shafir is
going to judge it as well and AR's got
the biggest grossest balls so they're
going to all be naked everyone's going
to be [__] naked dude can we convince
you to Callen if you want to win I need
a priest if you want to win over the
skankfest crowd this is the way to do it
you guys want win over the skankfest
crowd go do the [__] naked roast
right now it's out what a manipulative
tactic that was leou you
want naked take your clothes I'm going
to rape brenon sh take your clothes off
it sounds pretty
raping hey you know one really win this
crowd over you should kiss me in a
closet LS looks like a Disneyland pimp
doesn't
he that's a good [__] look I'm going
to take that as a compliment Brian
that's a compliment yeah Brian doesn't
roast I have a I have a different outfit
for every day of this Festival in fact
at the end of tonight I'm giving away
this [__] hat to one lucky fan In
This Crowd all right can I just I mean I
hate to be that guy but LS we all have a
different outfit for every day of he
keeps saying that thing to brag about
that you're not wearing the same clothes
the next day you have a different
ridiculous out I know Lou comes from
family
money guys I brought a change of clothes
for every day new socks it's a new Lewis
I'm talking underwear for Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday and I'm giving them
away and at the end of every day I'm
ringing him out and [__] flinging him
in the
audience hey what we're supposed to be
trashing brenon Trump what's going on
right now it's
ridiculous he's won them and they
realize he's better than you he is
better not at all the the one thing I
realized is everyone told everyone I
told everyone's told me everybody Berke
kryer everybody was like you and Louis
you just need to get together you guys
are going to love each other you're into
the same [__] he's built some stuff
you've built some stuff you guys are
going to like each other but we've never
really met face to face yeah and this is
it C what you've build is [__] insane
dude I bow down to you man like it's
it's an that's right you should bow down
to [__] yeah well yeah it's getting are
you out of your goddamn mind Louis shut
up dude I got take the Olive Branch you
lunatic I'll tell you what let me
control Louis's mic just just throw him
in a headlock and then Watch What
Happens what'll happen is sha will just
go like this and start giggling and then
it'll be a disaster Louis we do not have
your back please you are on your own
here hey I won't let him kill you
without going stop it's my
friend yeah yeah he learn he learned he
learned he we we have talked about this
before on the show could the Legion of
skanks the three of us collectively take
bre and Sh no because I think we could
three of us you [__] you [__]
[__] I don't know because if he gets if
he gets he's like Bam Bam and if he gets
that look that gorilla that sort of you
know before he pulls your limbs off it's
a weird LS let me explain to you why we
couldn't because I am immediately
fighting on Brendan's side okay I am
right away I'm jumping right over two on
two we're [__] let's get these [__]
it's going to be a movie where he levels
you and then it's going to be me and
Dave going oh
man hey we all said some things we
didn't mean back here man we're all
getting a little wild mushrooms are
going around what was the Tom Cruz movie
where he's like the the last two run
they always run that's be the Legion of
SC I don't know yeah all right you guys
we're not doing references anymore [__]
you guys all right a random Applause for
Brian came here right from the [__]
airport airport guys for you people for
you I ran here good thing my cardio's on
point huh guys Ser Brian texted me he
was like he's like dude there's weather
at the airport and then because he knew
that I would assume that he's lying he
started sending me videos of him at the
airport with like delays behind him and
other people mad yeah on the plane we
had a just holding the Hanah for the
rain yep I bought three I bought I
bought three [__] tickets and I
finally I get I get this one at 1:30 and
we're taxing and the guy goes our right
engine just went out and I went I got to
get the skank bestest and everybody went
yeah and then they made an
exception you that works that works in
American era but here's how long I've
known Brian even though he showed me the
videos I still thought he was Li I'm
still a liar I was like this [__]
I'll lie I'll lie he's backing out his
gank Fest I I have I have fans tweeting
at me like dude Brendan convinced Brian
to lie for him cuz Brendan didn't want
to show up that's what they were saying
they thought it was a whole [__] ruse
and then Brendan was here at 2:00
getting [__] down all day no no he
know getting down whole day no you know
what shop shop called me up shop called
me up we were talking at the airport he
goes like this he goes dude I go what he
goes the crowds I go uhoh he goes
they're [__] great they're really
nice thank you okay well let me just
say I I will say this okay I every year
at skang Fest there's always like some
comedians who it's their first time at
skang Fest and every year they always
say the same thing to me they always go
they're actually great yeah they're not
that bad it's because they look at you
[__] you know Savages it looks like
an audition it looks like a casting
couch for 60 days
in I did a little bit of time I can get
through it no to be I was terrified to
come though for sure you were you were
nervous super nervous he said it you did
say to me you're like dude like I got to
keep my head on a swivel I was like
they're not going to hurt you Brendon
relax I don't know so mean you can
double clothesline your way through this
place
systematically like Bo Jackson and
techmobile just taking off heads and
then make your way back through in even
lines like you're mowing a big
lawn by the time you get to the thrd row
they're going to be like no no no I'm
you just going to lay them out too once
once they're all down I come out and I
go oh they did a good job this week
oh they got it nice the lines are
perfect oh you guys don't have Lawns I'm
turn [__] you guys D [__] good La
good lawn joke good where are you at in
your life Dave's in his head right now
dude you guys [__] with Dave am I the
only guy with no tattoos this whole
[__] place no tattoos the only guy
with bare skin with Virgin skin Jes no
Dave has no tattoos either cuz he's a
tattoos oh he's Jewish cuz he's a Jew
butw but me and Louis have Dave Smith
tattoos check this out
what
uhoh he's got good skin tone doesn't he
look at that I don't tan properly look
at him there it is it's two half hearts
and his says Dave mine says Smith there
you go yeah I like that very much that
is adorable that's love [__] adorable
that's love for a Jew every time they
put them together a pedophile is
executed so how long you guys been
together how long has this been going on
skank 12 years 12 years the podast this
is the seventh skankfest wow the
seventh wow but how long have you guys
like you came up together in comedy and
me and Dave were friends before we were
comedians I was friends with Dave when I
was 19 or 20 years old we were like
roommates and then we became like young
I don't know why that one guy clapped so
much about us for roommates for
roommates [__] roommates D kinds of
Roommates we were young college
wrestling around somebody's [__] flies
out of his Speedo well we literally did
dude me and D I have cauliflower ear
because me and Dave Smith were just
[__] losers who would smoke weed and
do Jiu-Jitsu in the living
room you'd rent like the
videos UFC events and then we would
[__] do jiujitsu we didn't know
Jiu-Jitsu but we would smack each other
in the ears like I said you do some
light wrestling I yes but I have to I
always have to correct the record and
what would happen is me and lwis were
roommates and we would get drunk and
smoke weed and watch UFC and then Lewis
would shoot a double leg on me hell yeah
he does know he doesn't know how to
wrestle so yeah then yeah you would just
have to wrestle Lewis this was part if
you remember Lewis in his 20s this was
part of being friends with him that he
would just always start grappling with
you no I know I go I just set my defense
and I go no I'm your dancing friend yeah
yeah yeah I tried I tried we better uh
you told me you'd give me $5,000 if I
could take you down yeah and we were at
this we were at a party it was basically
a Snoop Doggy Dog Party it was a Snoop
Dogg is that what do the kids say any
anyway it was just no no L Cool our fans
are racist you're not going to impress
them with black people that's the and uh
and I think I tried to shoot a double
leg on you and you sprawled on me and I
still have I think my my ear was red for
almost a year cuz now notice I don't ask
to do any of this I haven't said
anything about fighting anybody all
their [__] I wanted to poke the bear
want to chill man there's something
about challenging a UFC fighter that
you're like dude I want to just test
myself and then you do it you're like
that was the worst idea I've ever had in
my entire life dude Bisping and Mickey G
both put me down with body shots just
for a giggle was that true yeah both of
them not good I'm I'm not going to do
striking but sometimes you can like jump
in his lap and then try to try to grab
his head or something okay I know I'm so
gay I got to come out of the closet
now um but yes you you and Dave same guy
clapping can I tell you something funny
about Lewis and Dave's novice training
mhm and maybe we'll give you guys a
treat here on the fighter and the kid
show one of my favorite things in the
world with lwis and Dave of the cuteness
of their relationship is a little
Training Method called Lewis versus hand
vers hand what is it Louis vers if you
guys want to see a little dose of Louis
V hand yeah yeah I I'll say right now
I'll tell you right now hand is not
really ready for what I have right now
damn okay so DN for you if you guys are
looking confused at this me and LS used
to play this game where Lewis would try
to fight my
hand you see if he can hit my hand
before I can move it out of the way so
he'd do this and I'd have to try to
punch it but his hand could strike me
back his hand is very fast I got to be
honest with you guys he's very elusive
try that it's uh it's not a good game
it's this gives me boyish laughter I I
love it so much can I try that let me
try that with I want to see Brian versus
hand try that well I don't I'm not I'm
not he's not going to I'm Viper quick B
Dave is not going to be willing to smack
you in your face that's the problem I'll
I'll slap you won't don't you won't just
slap me we everyone we have to
understand is I'm slap you unless
challeng hand you can't beat hand LS is
focusing on hands by the way I promise
you Brendan Shar could beat hand oh let
me tell you something hand needs a train
for Brendan Sha but Le but hand so the
funny of this is Lou seriously trying to
focus on hand by the way I think lwis
came up with this game wanted to play
it's the best training I've ever had in
my but hand slaps Lewis nonstop in the
face not sure I've gotten better Dave
have I not gotten better got have I not
improved in my recent training have I
not gotten
better Lis V
hand [__] here we go
by the way Dave's Dave's rather athletic
Dave's got some length of bone got a
long bone he just stood
up here it is sh over there Lewis is
built a little bit like a Samoan I like
it yeah he has Samoan legs H has Moana
legs yeah Louis's last name should be
Haka waga Haka Maka he's a ticket all
right now so now now what is this
now this is great all right all
right LS is already complaining hand
seems to you not hug before the fight
how gay is that you H I was doing oh I
was doing like an Anderson Silva Master
thing like
yeah hand seems to be on point
already it's a hand crowd every
everybody hand crowd all right oh
[__] oh oh there you
go that's good good technique move the
head move the head
talking that's not H you're not fighting
hand Lewis you've now attacked
[Applause]
arm by the way Dave was kind of lazy
with that slap yes that's how easy it is
for a hand to beat l so hard to beat
hand my God cuz hand just toys with
Louis it's not look like you were
looking for something in the dark you
know hands like a [__] ninja when's
the last time you guys did that uh we do
it twice a
week listen Okay 4 years old we uh we
did this once at the stand on joking
round for a minute recently but when we
were I'm like I'm 40 loose you're 41
when we were 20 and we were
roommates we did this so much
I can't me and leis used to constantly
do things where uh you take something
and pretend it's a knife and be like let
me see if I could fight you off with a
knife and the guy with the knife wins 10
out of 10 times man you just never never
you're like let me grab that you're like
ah he got me so bad no ability to take a
knife away from somebody knife makes so
much difference I watched a thing on
YouTube and it was like you had to
seriously fight somebody with a knife
and the advice was they were like first
thing first you're going to get stabbed
with this knife just so you know there's
no not getting stabbed if you're
fighting somebody with a knife it's
about avoiding like vital getting sliced
up yeah yeah dude apparently 90% of
people 90 or 87% of people are
right-handed and they stab you with
their right hand so they and they come
this way so you know fake news here guys
[__] yeah dude like that here bang and
then I didn't know you guys had all this
fight science on this show and where
wear
mesh around your midsection unless
you're shredded already like me huh you
need you need your my
whiskey sorry sorry sorry thank you
Brendon Brendon why are you such a
[__] sweetheart why does everyone
hate you so much what is happening I
know what is wrong with you people he
couldn't be any nicer I know that's what
happens you started it started it he did
[__] hilarious that was a great
response guess what Brendan gives to
charity but he doesn't tell anybody so
don't you feel bad now you [__] you
don't think that's help Brian you're
making it worse why do you hate him you
started
it that's to throw everybody else under
the bus you're like what's wrong with
you guys be cool bullies hey dude look
there's a lot there's a lot to hate on
there is a lot to hate on but I've never
but I've never ever have you ever heard
me say a bad word about you you've never
said a bad word about anybody you're the
nicest person I've ever met but what I
do but these people hate you so much I
don't understand I'm trying to
understand well you know what it is he
is 64 with all that [__] hair this is
new and shoulders for days it's a little
Annoying it is you know what I mean like
he's kind of good breeding stock so it's
fun to kind of even I kind of secretly
talk behind his back you know what I
mean I'm aware I'm aware I do what I I I
make fun of his speech it was you all
along it was never Bobby Lee's ex-wife
it was you no comment the whole thing I
did not I didn't say that I didn't say
it we broke I broke open the case I said
right here it's always who you least
suspect you piece of
[__] we find out it's Brian with a fake
account like this I don't
know oh what a puppet master that would
beant that would be a great last scene
of that movie though if they were like
it's been Callen the whole
time it's a slow
turn BR and if for no reason Brennan has
a button- down shirt and he's doing this
is he's taking his shirt off cuz he's
going to take his shirt off
gay man it's not gay it's just that you
have to show me your bul no it's just
like the thing that we said and then we
all suck each other's dicks for a while
you know what I mean and then like what
I'm so confused I don't know why not
it's only gay if you're smiling guys if
you're frowning it's okay but it it's
like the it was it was the Opie and
Anthony subreddit was like the [__]
like they were they turned on Opie and
Anthony in such a [__] crazy way and
then the fighter in the sub the fighter
and the kid subreddit it's like a
[__] dude what is I've never been on
it you've never been on it let's open it
right now on the big screen if we could
I'm kid
that You' never I I don't have a Reddit
account you you don't have to have a
Reddit account to go on to it I started
hearing about this yeah I don't uh I
don't even read my own comments but the
uh The Joe Rogan Reddit account is all
just trash Joe Rogan also it's a Reddit
turned into a weird thing where like
there's fan groups of people who hate
the thing that they're in the group of
yeah
nobody watches it more they know so much
yeah but isn't it a community like any
everybody's looking for some kind of
community oh don't make this you're
alone you kind of get to hate hate no my
thing is I almost making this way worse
I stay off it CU I'm now yeah but I
figured I figured that's their place to
go like big J should just kill himself
already I'm like yeah go say it who
gives a [__] I just I just you read my
post yeah and it taught me stay off
Reddit dude dude I leave into it I go on
red and I read all of the hate so then I
become desensitized to it and then I
don't actually care do you really read
it I go R it every day I have the app on
my phone what do you also post on the
fighter and the kid sub Reddit I'll post
right now a picture of me and you
yeah
yes this goes I read all of the insults
to me to develop thick skin I also eat
dirt to protect my immune system
this is the way this is the way that's
right I do it in in the horse stce with
a testicle cinch on yeah you can read
all this how's your mental health uh I
want to kill myself D let me tell you
not great look what he built he's going
to die early from a rage heart attack
probably um no I mean look you're you're
right it probably would be better it
probably would be better to not read all
of the hate but also I read it to like
make myself a little bit better it makes
me a little bit more self-aware can't
play baseball right now James I'm
reading hate comments on Reddit it's
making papa
better I will say that there yo I'm fat
dude I'm taking the chair with me when I
lean
forward I'm not fat I'm
hippie you're what what I'm Hipp white
hips just a little hippie you're the
only guy I know who gets away with
frosting his hair thank you am I right
he actually gets away with it if he was
anybody else I'd make I have so many
jokes about his hair it's worse you know
what it does it it becomes frosted tips
it's it is color at some point I put in
it and then that Fades out when you sit
down in the barage you go just Frost you
know don't make it well to be Brian to
be fair Jay loves frosting of all types
that's like one of his I like it in my
hair on my flakes yeah dude on his cake
yeah on my cake I know he does get away
with it we try so hard to not let Himes
get away's not losing any of it yeah but
Jay you don't go under the reddits you
don't let me be cooler in
1999 take that by the way you're not
talking to anyone here you're just Cory
heart like I we my sunglasses at night
so what happened to Cory I like when you
big J oerson an unrealized Life as a new
metal
singer I like the statement you should
have let me be cooler in 1999 isn't
directed at anyone here it's just like
you should have let me be cooler in '99
Philadelphia you're out there somewh my
neighborhood in Philadelphia and the
girls who didn't like
me J I love how you like started
dressing this way 9 and then you were
like you're like dude I'm just going to
wait until it becomes cool and it never
became cool
again keep waiting Louis yeah I couldn't
dress I guess in '99 it was all hip-hop
dog see Jay dresses so uncool you dress
too cool so the way you dress sucks and
the way you dress sucks you have to be
in the middle like a Dave Smith or a
Brian Ken like a boring [__] white
guy and a [__] cashmir black jeans
you know what I mean yeah I dress like a
[__] [__] I understand this sucks
I I like that look I like it you like it
I like that look dude come on don't be
so hard on yourself you wear a different
outfit every
[Laughter]
day Louis give yourself a little bit of
a break youve brought a daily outfit
what do you guys think you'd be this
such a [__] weird job that we do what
do you think you'd be doing for real
raping exactly me raping personally jail
as a profession not aob you be doing if
you weren't doing this I'd probably
storm the capital yeah oh dude I you
would be such a good Capital Stormer man
God I know
dude you just jump over the [__]
fence with one Leap yeah man sha we
really could have used you on the sixth
that's all I'm saying oh my God we
really needed shs out he would have
choked out the [__] Shaman guy and
then put his face paint on himself I am
your king
now I am your king I don't approve of
what happened there that day for the
record but when it's time you'll Now dog
whistle dog
whistle you know there are some
attractive women at skankfest which I I
was expecting to see dude that's so
that's so cool that you would come here
after those cancelled flights and then
lie to everybody like that that is
really want to say thank you for putting
on your best face today all of you yo
skank fist gets hotter and hotter every
year dude
it's like physically hotter we're in the
desert you're all ugly people Everyone
Gets fatter and the space gets smaller
we're all
hotter yeah no this chick's pretty hot
and then uh yep well don't don't say
don't say this chick is pretty hot she's
hot she's pretty hot dude I mean look
[__] Sha's not trying to walk into
his truck I'll tell you that much oh is
that mod dick and I do and I do have a
new truck you have a new truck dude you
ain't walking this check to your truck
let's get real dude I know yeah you
[__] maybe look at her in the
rearview mirror as you drive away yeah
yeah they're all looking at
shop if you're thinking about not
throwing it all away I'll tell you that
this young lady can queef on command she
can queef on command this girl right
here oh she's like a skankfest regular
no she won a so she's wearing a Golden
Ticket because she can qu she won a
contest she queefs on command really she
can just she does she looks like she
looks like a Dallas Cowboy a cheerleader
in who goes to church also queef on
command was the original name for the
fighter in the kid
podcast facts and I wish we called it
that no one's safe burn no one's safe
burn [__] burn on that congrats on
your skills congrats
yeah were your parents like how'd you
get the gold
pass yeah and she hasn't spoken to her
dad in years Super Christian she's
rebelling
she didn't ask how or no details you
couldn't tell her she was proud of your
mother and you couldn't tell her that it
was queefing and dunking a
basketball good for you though also when
you hear a woman talk like isn't it kind
of kind of funny you're like dude
sometimes they choose the podcast you're
like that's crazy right it's nuts their
[__] voices are the worst spon and
kid has no female fans we don't know
what it's like L really W oh there's one
right there oh we have one oh wow all
right thank you oh surprise surprise the
[__] cyborg lady is
but attractive but attractive so [__]
you Jay that's lady hey welcome ex mocka
are you
guys X that's that's how he gets away
with the Frosted tip yes the kids's
quick [__] Luna vashan in the front
row loves the fighter and the kid oh
[__] I've been a fan for a long I love
what you guys do the way you broke down
the return of Nate Di this was
remarkable your banter is
[Music]
unmatched [__] I'm sorry I'm sorry
they're both very blonde though and you
should breed your children would get
lost in snow they have three kids oh you
have three kids by the way these two
these two will they will swing they will
do crazy [__] oh yeah swingers they send
me DMS all the time they're like he's
like please [__] my wife please if you
could wow this guy regularly asked me to
[__]
he look like a rough kid too he got some
cauliflower ear looks you guys are the
fight experts here but they look like
they had their three kids not from sex
but from Muay Thai
training accidental stayed in the grip
too long and he came that's it seeped in
Spartans spart are you guys
Fighters you're black belt Jiu-Jitsu in
Jiu-Jitsu I can see it on your body my
friend congratulations I have't had a
chance to take you in all right hold on
if we trade out Dave could me this guy
and Jay take sha I think me this guy and
he's a [__] black belt come on that
me but but what what kind of did you
compete like competitive black belt yeah
might might be a problem he might be a
problem he's a thick kid's can I make a
p you're forgetting one thing leis me in
the
background they always forget about me
everyone and Fighter the kid if you want
to edit this out feel free to it's a
strange thought but you shouldn't hit
your ladies
fellas but if you got to show them
what's what you could do worse than
doing jiujitsu to them you got to show
them what's that doesn't answer that
doesn't raise any questions the next day
if you armar your wife no one's ever
like what happened to your eye and
you're like oh I was in a knee bar I had
to submit no I think you should I think
I think rear naked choking your wife
till you put her out should be just what
you do to end a
dispute
yeah unpopular maybe
but and don't but if you do it got dark
fellas body work yeah listen I'm not
going to co-sign everything that was
just set up here Dave's got a huge heart
this is so inappropriate no one takes a
woman I can't control what turns me on
all right but I will say if you and LS
and Jay can beat Brendan sha in a fight
you will earn yourself a shot at hand
so that's and H's been ducking you for a
long time sir it's the next level of
training H's been picking his fights for
years only if you beat hand now now le
Lewis will have sex with your wife I how
much Lewis is training how much are you
training right now I'm training a lot
right now fight coming up November 4th
Carnival of
combat no no just boxing right now I'm
old I have bad knees okay why are your
knees so bad from what from Jiu-Jitsu
sucking [__] just getting on my knees J
seriously getting down there and blowing
dudes not you I always go for the lwh
hanging fruit am I
right am I
right no yeah I got bad I'm fighting
November 4th Carnival of combat me
versus Tim butterly I don't know if he's
in the room right now but I'm going to
[__] Tim butterly up what's up baby boy
damn let go team Carnival of combat one
I've got bad
knees streaming Tim I was just working
with Tim we were on the same show he
could be a handful though yeah yeah
Tim's a bad [__] dude purple
belt has some boy tie fights yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but does he move his head
Brandon does he [__] move his head he
has that white you know what I'm saying
I'm a [__] Cobra he does he's got
like U like he's from the fighting city
of Philadelphia so this one's tough for
me I'm from Patterson New Jersey dude
it's one of the most dangerous places in
the [__] world you moved when you
were 3 months old you're from Rockland
County and everyone called you the n
word stop
it and you know what they were right I
that's that's what a sign of what a
great neighborhood you lived in Louis
sure did they thought you were the black
guy they did I just love that these guys
are smoking it's so rare I'm in I live
in a world where everybody does coal
plunges in the morning and has seared
elk and half a yam if they've earned it
and these [__] guys are just like
videotaping for me you [__] [__] you
know ansers for live long for what dude
I agree I like hey B when I argue with
you on politics you know I don't know
[__] about politics I'm just
regurgitating and it's a very CT version
of it it's not good but he's a
Libertarian I'm right with him this is
how this is how stupid libertarianism is
Brendan scha agrees with it
correct Brendan [__] him up in the name
of
Liberty in the name of Liberty now
listen choke out like an eagle now
squeeze him till he poos am I just
regurgitating someone smarter than me
sure but that's how it works that's how
all right it's called trickle down
effect we're all smart sort pass it down
until someone punches Lewis in the
face Brandon will you punch me in the
arm really hard I want to see how hard
you punch oh dude I want to feel it dude
please I want to feel it dude let's go
blow for blow hold on Brandon rattle him
he hates it oh man this is this is going
to be bad he hates dude no you got a
fight give him what he deserves Lou you
got a fight coming up what are you doing
you got a fight coming up though go go
go go Brandon turn your shoulders I
don't want to I don't the hold on he's
sitting it can't be that hard wait wait
wait stop stop Brandon you have to see
through the target
yes you're punching through the dude I
am so I'm sweating now I'm soaking yo I
think if you hit LS here he shuts off
yes as long as he doesn't use his karate
will be okay let's see dude he's sitting
down I'm serious you could hit me as
hard as you can dud but Lou you got a
box you're going to get a Charlie no
dude a punch in the arm dude whatever
brendon's gay dude how about that oh
Jesus Brandon's gay Brandon's gay
Brandon's gay keep your arm close to
your body dude I bet you Brandon punches
like a
[__] oh oh you missed me and punched me
in my rib it went arm to tit oh my God
it was like the JFK bullet it
ricocheted it's it's the silky shirt
silky shirt he hit me twice you piece of
[__] it was so meaty cheater oh God he
leaned in last second too yeah that
doesn't feel good
sorry remember I didn't want to do this
you it's never your idea huh never will
you come Brendon offred he said I'm
training tomorrow morning with uh Team
rattlesnake
will you come and train with Team
rattles tomorrow morning yeah I'm down
what time though my CU bus play at 9:30
wait your what my CU bus football I know
you guys don't football dude football
yeah I'll tell you this he grabbed he
grabbed Michael Rapaport in the hallway
after fighting Michael was like I want
to I want to see what you got and
Brendon goes what do you want to do and
he goes I don't know and he goes let me
put you in a headlock and Brendon goes
I've never seen anything like that
before and and then Michael grabbed him
in a headlock and Michael's a big guy
and then Brennan I saw him start to
giggle and then he grabbed Michael and
just he went like that and he popped he
broke his
rib yeah he went he went and my went oh
oh my rib oh no and then he broke his
rib you accidentally broke his rib yes
and no he's also a farle couck
that's that is that is true but we love
him but we love him I love him but chill
out on the rants on Instagram yeah dud
we do not like Michael Rapaport on the
Legion of skanks dude we are Ari shafir
fans all the way here dude [__] Michael
Rapaport I'll say it right now but do
Ari and Rapaport not like each other no
Michael Rapaport punched AR punched AR
in the face twice really well he slapped
him uh slapped let me tell you a little
story about a Jew who turned the other
cheek okay he like Moses himself one of
them one of them was the god of men and
the other is president of the Legion of
skank podcast all right so they
all but but why was rap Port so mad at
art oh I think Ari did something wrong
that would be my guess yeah AR was
something wrong that would be my if I
had to get wait was the it might have
been the Kobe thing no I no I think well
it can't be the Kobe thing I think I
think Rapaport started trashing Ari for
the Kobe thing and then Ari got really
personal with
Rapaport no I don't think it was his
wife it was about he has like stalking
charges and [__] like Michael R Fort and
stuff he started calling like like a
harassing women and real ass dude real
ass dude and then he came for Ari boy
that got he brought it I'll see you guys
later [__] yo when and then that was
when Rapaport was hanging out withan
Gill you see when Callen checks out on
conversation guys it's been good for you
all right I got I got another plane to
catch when whenever it gets too hot and
heavy Count's like how fortunate are we
to be up there I know I want everybody
get along I like them
both oh he's got he got this old
accusation that came up count what the
the engine's working okay I'm back on my
plane see you guys later one of my fav
fix the engine have a good one you know
one of my favorite things that was that
was when Shane was hanging out Rapa port
a bit and didn't want to [__] on Rapa
Port when that was all happening and
then uh we were like yo what do you
think about what he did to Ari and Shane
goes yo Rapa Port said it's on [__]
site and it was on site dude he showed
up and came right up to AR
and I will say Point by rap look I I do
have a weird amount of respect when
celebrities are willing to just throw
down I mean I I personally have had to
stop rap report from fighting when I
didn't even know we were doing a movie
I'm an actor and we uh doesn't matter
we're show my real actually after this
it's so F it's only 40 minutes but um
but uh but and I do drama as well but I
I'll talk about my stage experience a
little bit later do you guys have a
minute so um but we're doing this movie
and [__] this guy we're at a bar and
raps a big kid and I don't know rap that
well and the guy keeps asking you know
want to call him rap dude no see that
see that he was pretty comfy to me [__]
hang I don't know him I don't know rapid
do that much but it's like uh look I
mean we have a time sharing Tahoe but
other than that and we practice Muay
Thai together his low kicks are stupid
so here I am I'm I'm hanging out with
Mike anyway no but uh he [__] this
guy just kept getting in his face but
kind of getting a little obnoxious and
asking for pictures and and rap out of
[__] nowhere just went hey bro I
[__] had it with you and he and he
came at him and I had to get in front of
him I had to stop him respect the rap
yeah yeah how big was the guy he was
going at [__] he was uh 68 yeah he it
was actually not it wasn't a guy it was
a girl but still okay yeah but it was
very it was very scary story he was so
mad you guys guys the story holds the
story hold story holds made the story up
for the podcast but the thing is no true
story true story has anyone ever tried
fighting you you talk a lot I I don't
know you talk a lot of [__] about a
bunch of people or just yeah I mean I
have I've
had yeah no you're the only one you're
the only one you spr the love W shop
shop shop sh sh all right all right
doggy how many of my friends have tried
to fight me just Kurt
mezer Kim conden every finger you put
out that arm is rattled still
well I can't actually move this finger
there's like some sort of nerve damage
that is going on right
now I'm I'm a terrible roaster cuz I I I
could never roast I would lose that
battle I wouldn't even know how to start
it's the only it's the only time I draw
a blank so [__] sweet the one it's
Brian's been doing ComEd for a hot
second but when it comes to like being
mean roasted it's not your thing I can't
be mean it's not your thing no you can
be mean go if I see an opening [__]
what's up with your [__] smooth skin
leis and your [__] strong jaw but
back to you cuz you you talk [__] you
guys do your thing have have you had an
encounter outside your friend I have I
well there was one there was uh that uh
there was a kid this uh comedian in New
York named Jake I won't even say his
last name I wouldn't give him that much
credit but he so we we right all right
fine fine fine fine The Snake
Robertson Robert well good thing we
brought him Jake come on now no I'm just
kidding no no no there was a kid when we
got kicked out of the creek and Cave we
we we ended up having m ylis on the
Legion of skanks podcast who's like a
right-wing like gay troll dude he's
[__] he's hilarious but he's he's
genuinely harmless but the the people on
the left hated this guy so we had him on
the show and we we we ended up moving
our show from the creek in the cave
Rebecca Trent who's one of the owners of
this festival with me one of my partners
we ended up moving from her Club because
of the discourse that came from us
having [__] Rebecca I forgot about that
yeah I'm kidding I love you thank you um
but one of the there was like a a lefty
comedian who was like talking a lot of
[__] online like a ton of [__] online
about all of us yeah and then I saw him
at a comedy club once and then I just
saw red dude I started talking [__] to
him but he was all right to be let me
tell the story better than lisis ever
will himself umir he wasn't just you'll
never [__] you
hand you son of a [__] uh so elusive he
wasn't he wasn't just talking [__] he
crossed a line where he was like he was
tell back then throwing milk shakes on
people was like a big thing like right
Wingers days he was uh he was like but
wouldn't it be funny if we all brought
milkshakes to the creek and Cave like he
was trying to kind of instigate people
and then Big Jay was into the idea he
was like dude they're bringing
milkshakes just [__] rules I'm like
this is why I started doing comedy one
day they'll shower me with milkshakes
and my grandmother said you're living a
dream Lewis and you fight this man yeah
that's not a very so and then it just
but but it was just kind of like this
weird thing where he was kind of trying
to instigate like a thing to go down and
then the [__] talking got more and more
and more on Twitter like it was it was
not good like cross the line cuz you'll
fire back online you oh yeah I just go
like I I dude if I get on a flight if
anybody in the world you can have one
follower if you say anything about me on
Twitter if I'm on a flight I will spend
the entire flight going back at you
really yes the whole flight amazing the
whole I kind of love it yeah I've gotten
those taking a [__] I couldn't do it
never on a flight but taking a [__] I've
been like I looked and now I got to
respond
yep I watched that Cloverfield Lane
movie uh and I'd already seen it but I
watched it again instead of just mixing
it up online with other you mix it up
online all the time dude Dave lives in
this world of like politics so he it's
not only like like I'll [__] around with
like trolls and talk [__] which is
whatever right I'm just bored Dave has
like they care about what they're
talking about they're like it's about
their lives and they're [__] going at
each other I see your Tweet you care
about what you talk about too my shit's
just smarter yeah but D Dave were you in
the debate Club no really interesting no
no no Dave was like he was like he was
an idiot kid he was like a [__]
burnout like [__] Stone I was you're
telling me there's a
chance I I I was not a good student or
anything like that ever I was I was a
[__] I was a pothead and a [__] up
and uh I I yeah I just did I did enough
school so I wouldn't get kicked off the
basketball team and then I still got
kicked off the basketball team because I
didn't calibrate right just that one
year and Dave Dave kept that same sort
of attitude uh toward basketball right
up until the Legion of sanks basketball
game against I do I say by the way I I
still keep the attitude with the podcast
I try to get enough just enough just to
make just enough jokes off that I don't
get kicked off of this podcast you know
what I mean like at least you're just
like why is Dave even here and then I
say one funny thing and they're like
keep him another episode all right fine
Dave buys himself one month every
episode it's just always a little bit
ahead of it that's worked out for me
whatever all right I hey Dave why was
there only one set of footprints in the
sand he's like I was home in New
Jersey I don't know I don't think I came
in that day I was tired yeah Dave hates
you people you should know anyway hey
that is only true for 80% of you oh so
you so you ended up almost fighting Jake
uh that was the only time then almost I
almost got into a fight with Kurt mezer
on live on Legion of sanks at The Comedy
Store oh wow a real fight a real fight
with her a real fight dud instead I had
water thrown on me no no no it was it
was whiskey whiskey thrown in my face
you did no I threw a cup of whiskey at
Kurt meter's big [__] ugly head and
you blocked it yo I mean it was catlike
why have you ever spoken to Kurt mezer
you don't be nice to me I've known him a
long time no he's he is the worst um no
I love Kurt he's the man we went on tour
together we been
we made up yeah but so this guy you got
in the in his face he backed down oh he
backed down dude it's so funny that when
you go through these things anytime you
tell the story of like where I almost
fought this guy and I know the story and
I'm like no it was a whole thing but
then when you start telling it you're
like this sounds really stupid man like
this was not worth fighting over like
first the thing with Jake we were like
no no no but he tweeted a thing you know
so like I'm like I was with SH we were
in a we were in your Porsche back in the
back in the day when you were still
fighting uhhuh and this [__] guy this
guy had those R hold on let me let me
let me just say right now let me point
this out they don't this is the moment
this is it this is the I just pinpointed
the moment why it's not even Brendan's
fault it's Brian's fault I know these
people will never own a Porsche I know
they hated that you just said that it
doesn't matter cuz they [__] about
for a Porsche he doesn't give a [__] I
drive a Dodge Ram this's but the thing
about they'll drive it every day though
he doesn't keep it there he'll [__] hey
you're not helping he doesn't he's like
yo when this guy inevitably [__] your
girlfriend hey guys don't [__] listen
if you all pulled your money together
you could get a Kia so don't listen to
these guys all right tell you right you
can get a key of cocaine let's party
tonight I might do cocaine on thisp this
guy this guy was this guy was trying to
fight Brennan he was driving us down and
pulling up next to him and like just
literally trying to fight [__] like
getting behind us and tailgating P
because I guess
Brennan
cut and the guy was like the guy was
like 4 and kind of pudy and I was like
you're about to get [__] like not even
beat up and then remember I I think I
said I can't remember what I did said to
him but I I looked at him and I go if he
gets mad he's going to bust and that's
all I said it's all it took what yeah I
just it was you said the genuine gayest
thing you could have Poss so gay no I
didn't like I didn't like that I looked
at guy got confused he got confused I go
nobody's busting anywhere he's going to
[__] go oh [__] when you talk [__]
this guy
comes you're spray
down man salty loads of Fury shooting
wide
arcs oh just ropes all over your face
dude you're [__] map of Hawaii on your
new truck you [__] it's your funeral
[__] you want you're going to be
drowning and [__]
dude uh yeah I that's the thing like the
the road rate that's the thing that
happens with me very often my road rage
you so Brendon I've heard stories before
like Chuck Liddell and other guys like
that they'll say like when you're a UFC
fighter there are people who almost like
pick fights with you never had I also
don't hang out at get the [__] out of
there I don't I don't hang out but also
when I did when I was younger I it's the
energy they're giving out like you have
that energy like I'm the toughest dude
in here then guy's like all right [__]
like if there's Alpha dudes then you're
going to challenge them well guys who
really guys who really know how to fight
they don't act like that no because they
don't need to prove anything it's guys
like me that everywhere I need to prove
that I'm tough I'm always imagining my
mother hitting me again in every
interaction I have ever well I've never
I'm not I'm not going to mention names
but I will tell a story where where you
did get please make this a better story
no where you got you got CH where they
said there there were some people that
called you and said Hey listen don't
worry nobody's going to [__] with you
and you said because you got in a little
tiff with someone it was okay he got in
a little tiff with someone who was might
be might have might or might not have
been a pro fighter and then one of the
guys at the gym called Brennan and said
hey dude don't worry nobody's GNA [__]
with you and Brendan and then I was the
only time I ever saw you go hold on hold
on do you think I'm [__] afraid of
you guys do you and you said don't get
it twisted I was a heavyweight I'll come
to your gym lock the door line everybody
up and [__] kill all of you I feel
like Brian's still not helping he's not
helping well they right PR
person he has humility he's been nothing
but a sweetheart and a nice guy this
[__] [__] is just bragging about all
of these
awesome no no no no let me tell you a
story about Brendan okay one time he
told me he has the biggest dick in
America okay and I remember he looked me
right in the face and then he told me
that non and then we get done and Brian
be like you're cocky man you know the
hottest girl you've ever seen he had the
shoer away beat it you fat pig he thinks
she
is you guys are so [__] dude no we
could we look I think we can I think we
could win the fighter the kid subreddit
back for Bron J there's a way there's a
path get it back baby there is a path a
path all in I'm all in there is a path
what do you think what do you think the
hate was about I couldn't figure it out
I for real do you think it's more of
Brian what that well I I say it only
because like look there's like a zillion
things like you're a former fighter you
came in with a name to Comedy so you got
fast-tracked Y in so many ways and put
in the public eye and then people behind
keyboards and again you're the guy in
their mind who like bull [__] their
yeah [__] their so they're just like
[__] this pretty mother [__] you know he
can't be funny I don't have a problem
with that they start with hate but
that's stuff I get that's stuff I get
when they go when they make it personal
that's that's where it hurts my feelings
oh no for sure I'm saying you can clown
the comedy my fight picks all it does
hurt his feelings but when it when when
they come for the family yeah but by the
way hold on that's [__] awesome that
you just you admit it it hurt your
feelings and it does hurt our feelings
you [__] we read we read the
comments it's going to be a group hug
he's going to you guys line up and he's
going to hug everybody I he like this
with his arm to hug I think here's the
thing comedy fans in general are [__]
nerds right most most comedy fans I'm a
comedy fan dude we didn't have an easy
path I think the perception on you is
that you've had an easy path you're
you're a good-looking dude you're in
shape you're you're an athlete and then
you got into comedy and you sort of had
a kind of easy yeah such an easy path
fist fighting Miro
crocop yeah what an easy path you mic
yeah I had I had to do open mics and
this guy just
fist Bron Shaw walking through the
raindrops
again no but but you're right but as far
as the comedy like I didn't anticipate
any of it I I I I and I wish I was
smarter to see it cuz when my agent goes
hey Showtime with give special I'm like
oh my God I'm be just like them I didn't
realize and I tried to talk him out of
it you and Rogan did I tried to talk we
almost got in a physical fight I was
like oh they're just haters but then but
what happens is you start killing you're
you're young comic your audience is
there to see you so you're doing well
you're like I can do a [__] shorttime
special and then you realize the people
at Showtime have no [__] clue about
comedy and I didn't realize the backlash
and then but even like my first set was
at The Comedy Store I didn't realize how
big of a deal that was I'm like oh
everyone's going to dig this I'm at the
commi store but I should have never been
there the Showtime special I should have
never gotten that right I thought most
Comics would be like dude for two years
this is awesome no people like yeah I
knew I knew it was happen and to your
credit you even said he text me you go
[__] dude you were trying to save me
from all this I was like the day after
the day after Dro My Text count I
apologized like you're right brother I
should have listened to you dude no no
comic in the world should be on tape for
the first like 5 to eight years minimum
of Comedy well you know what's funny
wasn't it so I remember we were talking
outside BR you were you were talking at
one point and telling the D almost like
a doc you thing yes yes yes yes it
should have been a with like a little
bit of Comedy but like kind of him
getting into comedy yes but you know
what it was Showtime said to him do this
special he felt he had to like deliver
what are we having a fight what happened
what's going on [__] right now you
need my friend to come [__] you up right
now what's going on no I think it's told
want to be I think we need I think we
need hand oh no they're just playing
around uh they're just hand
fighting no yeah but I I think
anticipate that but then also you got to
realize I'm new in comedy Showtime
offers me more money than I ever made
fighting I'm like I'm doing the hour on
the road anyway this would be cool like
people will know I've only been in two
years it just doesn't work that way
because when it's a major Network
special they go well B Bill Burr's on
there Sebastian meis Sebastian's on
there and then you're following by by
the way I watch Brenan just give up on
saying Mana scalco did you guys I've
been I've been doing this way too longed
I I know my I know my Sebastian M anyway
so that was a great that was great
Sebastian man we all know who the [__]
I'm talking about we all know I know
there's more C's than you'd think yeah
and so to be safe I always go Sebastian
maniss cow
Coke but yeah I I didn't see that coming
but from my perspective it was like big
bag more money I've ever made I got the
hour anyways [__] it let's put it out
but in hindsight I would have never done
that you would have never done it you
would think it back I in hindsight I
wouldn't post anything Tom 10 years deep
I'm only eight in yeah so I would wait
till the 10 year mark there's a reason
they say wait till dud live and learn
you live by your mistakes I I learned
the hardest dude I remember so when I
was like uh like
cool be [__] cool so so when me and
lwis were like a few years into comedy J
you had been doing it a bit longer but
you remember John mayor started doing uh
standup and he immediately started
working at the comedy seller every night
and I remember there'd be these young
comics and even I was a young comic at
the time too but like at the shitty
shows we'd be at and they' be like this
such [__] John Mayor just gets to go
do the comedy seller and you're like
well where the [__] do you think John
Mayor is going to go yeah signed upth
list you think John Mayor is going to be
in an open mic with you well I will say
something let me just say but I remember
even talking about it at the time and
you go look I know you think that's
[__] easy for him cuz he gets past
cuz yeah he's [__] Jennifer Aniston
so he's not going to be where you are
you know what I mean he's going to be
somewhere better than that but the but
there's also like a whole flip side
which is that this motherfucker's got to
follow davel tonight which is like a
which is a crazy situation for someone
who's never done stand baptism by fire
to do there's challenges to that side
also y can I say one of my favorite
stories of all time when John Mayor was
doing comedy at the seller he bumped the
show back a bunch and David tell was
sitting in the hallway watching him a
little or no David David tell went on
stage he was on stage doing a set and
he's leaning on the seller has a piano
on stage and he just leaning on that he
uh he's busting brother John mayor's
balls he's giving him like the why you
here kind of thing and John Mayor
eventually goes H Come On Dave we're all
Comics
here and Dave AEL started punching piano
keys and he goes
re and then he points to the guy in the
front row he goes how long was your
really but yeah that's sort of the thing
like the reality is the seller which was
at the time one of the most the most
respected comedy club in the world
shouldn't have put John Mayor on they
should have said you know what you got
to be a comic yeah that's on them I'm
not saying maybe you shouldn't have been
in a room with a lot of people but I'm
saying that it's up to us as as whatever
we are be a standard someone has [__]
standard that's that's like the same
thing you'll see in my comments or maybe
in yours on red like oh aren't you
playing the mothership Brenan I don't
deserve to be there I don't I I I and me
and Rogan had this conversation I'm not
there yet there there's guys like you
like to me and I'm not just saying big J
is one top five doing it right now so
yeah I I
am his special was insane so I see that
stuff I see Tim Dylan I see Mark Norman
those are Lou J Gomez Dave Smith all
these guys 100% sh he was going to get t
yeah I was going to get to
you got to go through like 30 more
comments I'll get there I'll get there
but so I shouldn't be there I I don't
want to go there and get backlash like I
want when they invite me to be a
headliner I'll know it's my time I don't
want to recreate The Comedy Store for me
I don't stand up stand up lets you know
stand up lets you
know you can't fake stand up and you
can't you can't fake comedy you can't
fake fighting but you also that a homer
card God damn it dude if you keep doing
like inevitably you're going to like
grow as a thing someone like John Mayor
is a great example like he did it even
though he was able to go in as you with
a name is able to go into these big
clubs right away do matter the thing was
eventually you're going to have to
really stick it out and grind these
spots out and John Mayor was like I know
I'm going to go like [__] Katy Perry or
whatever like bren's going to do 20
minutes after this guys you ready too
hard it's too hard it's too hard yeah
but you're also listen I appreciate
everything you're saying and and I I
think you're right about a lot of it
you're and you're kind of like being
honest about where are but also at the
same time you're not what John Mayor did
cuz you've actually been sticking this
out for a long
time yeah dude well that's true but
you've been doing listen man you were a
[__] like [__] top 10 UFC
heavyweight you went and made a [__]
an incredibly successful podcast and
you've you're developing your stand well
I mean it was it was going hot for a
while the point is
years 10 years you're doing your [__]
you're doing your [__] thing bro so
don't like beat up on yourself too much
it's like like yeah you [__] live and
learn but you're you're a good guy dude
dude and you [__] came out to skank
fest with these [__] Savages
oh when when literally everybody on your
[__] subr it talk [__] and they were
like dude they're going to bail they're
not going to show up no dude this guy
was here all [__] day walk through
the hallway shaking hands with people be
here tomorrow too Brandon I I I'll
always do scang Fest if you have me I'll
be here every year buddy open invite
doggy yeah always I think I speak for
Brian when I say you pick yourself up by
the bootstraps you get in a Lamborghini
and you [__] the hottest chick you want
to here in Las Vegas tonight yeah
dude or your Ferrari it's only going to
get better from here you go look out of
that beautiful view and I'm sure your
awesome
house and on that note you guys this has
been awesome we love you guys thank
bless St best big J Dave Lewis thank you
brother thank you guys
yeah